breaking news from london where a court
has ruled ricky wikileaks founder julian
assange can be extradited to the united
states to face espionage and other
charges ramion ascencio is outside the
court that announced that decision a
short time ago raymie good morning
nate good morning to you that's right
and it has been pretty crowded all
morning here outside the british high
court and that's because whatever
washington thinks of julian assange he
still has many supporters who say he
exposed american wrongdoing in
afghanistan and iraq but today british
judges did rule in favor of the united
states opening the door to assange's
extradition in total he's facing 18
charges that includes espionage charges
of conspiring to hack government
computers and releasing confidential
documents and this really has been a
chapter a full year in the making
today's decision actually runs counter
to an earlier lower district court
ruling that blocked assange's
extradition because it fears he would be
sent to a super supermax penitentiary in
florence colorado and then potentially
take his own life you might remember
assange had also spent seven years
seeking asylum in the ecuadorian embassy
here in london before being hauled out
in 2019
and subsequently arrested all this to
say is that this saga continues to go on
and it's not over yet and actually
assange may not end up in the united
states at all that's because there are
still several illegal hurdles to come
including a further final appeal at the
british supreme court tony
the saga there continues ramiro sensei
in london for us raymie thank you very
much